tous ces schémas ne sont pas
nécessairement frauduleux il faut quand
même bien distinguer qu' il y à la
fraude la côte est qui est sanctionnable
pour lequel l'administration fiscale est
là et use de tous les moyens prévus par
la loi pour la réprimer et
l'optimisation qui dans notre société de
liberté reste encore un droit même si le
mot fait tâche maintenant même nous on
évite de l'utiliser mais n'en demeure
pas moins que quel soit agressive ou pas
agressive elle est soit du bon côté de
la loi soit du mauvais côté de la loi il
ya quand même des marqueurs objectif qui
permette de de la cerner et de la classe
et
ensuite il faut distinguer le les
problématiques de fiscalité et les
problématiques de confidentialité je
pense que on ne peut pas retirer aux
gens le souhait de rester discrets sur
leur investissement
[Musique]